everyone today I wanted to talk quickly
about what to do when you have
unsupported parents so I recently got
asked by one of my YouTube subscribers
who's a teenager we'll call him Jay and
he wanted to be a motivational speaker
and so I invited him into my mastermind
group tgim for one week just to and ask
his question to the group and get some
feedback and support as well as this
video for me and here's his problems he
was a teenager he wants to be a
motivational speaker he wants to start
improving his skills who wants launching
youtube channel to start to get some
practice and his parents laughed at his
face they laughed at him said he can't
do it said nobody would ever listen to
his advice and this is something that
he's holding herself back from doing
something he really wants to do but he's
not doing it because he doesn't have to
support his family and so he wanted our
feedback and so this this drives me nuts
it drives me nuts because having
unsupportive friends and family on the
little man in your life will hold you
back always from doing something great
you have to first of all understand that
if you want to be happy you want to be
fulfilled you want to make a lot of
money you want to have a big impact on
this world the only way that is going to
happen is if you follow your passion and
do what makes you come alive if you do
what your parents tell you to do if you
do your friends think you should do then
you're living somebody else's version of
your life instead of your own version of
your life and there's no way that you're
going to be a big success by living
somebody else's version okay don't let
them put their experiences and their
thought processes and their biases on
you to drive you down a path for you to
want to go whatever it is you want to
learn go and learn you want to try try
it your launch on youtube channel to
practice being a speaker practice being
the speaker put it up you always want to
do with this mean you're young now just
a teenager you've got a huge light path
ahead of you you always want to do the
things that make you [ __ ] a lot and get
you excited you don't want to be the guy
like most people who look back on their
life right here 40 50 60 looking back to
when you were 19 s a man I really wish I
started right living with that regret
for the rest of your life don't let that
be you if you want something you go
after right now
your environment sucks and that's the
first thing that you need to change and
I'm not saying get new parents I'm sure
they love you and I'm sure their advice
it there they're giving you is out of
love right they want to see me
successful just their approach totally
sucks and your environment is terrible
and so what you need to start doing is
changing your environment what I would
recommend is look at people who inspire
you look at speakers that you look up to
and say I want to be like that guy that
girl surround yourself with that right
start your day every day with a video
from a speaker you look up to have stuff
on your wall have statues have things
that support you that build you up that
make you want to be great if you want to
be great you have to surround yourself
with greatness that's the only way that
it happens and if you don't have
greatness around you if you have
mediocrity around you guess what you're
going to be so start changing your
environment from the media you consume
the books you read the videos you watch
your morning routine your daily schedule
it's got to support you to being up here
right you can't even see it gets off the
screen up here that's what you gotta be
where right now you're super low right
and if you continue on this path you're
going to live the life that your parents
are living and that's not the path that
you want to go down in terms of adding
value and creating content people will
listen to I have two things to offer you
advice on one I would start with things
that you know about okay so what have
you gone through to this point in your
life right so you're a teenager you need
to learn some lessons along the way it
may not be a long road you may not have
you know 80 years of experience to give
to somebody but you've learned some
things and you can help people who are
still younger than you so what lessons
can you give to people who are two three
four five six years younger than you
because they're on YouTube man they are
on YouTube they're looking for advice
you looking for help and you know they
don't look up to the 40 50 year olds
right they want someone who can relate
to them and so talking to those people
are are people who can be inspired by
your message right you may not inspire
your 40 year old 50 year old parents
whatever you may but depending on the
message you may not and that's okay look
to the people that you can help be
authentic
right anything that you're giving advice
on it's something that you've
experienced something that you feel not
something that you're just like
researching and trying to get a grasp on
write something that ah hits you here
that's what you want to talk about I'm
passion about this video it's coming
through it's more exciting that has more
impact enough i'm talking like this and
i'm trying to research any say you need
to follow your passion because it's
really important right like if i read
off some quote it's not legit it's got
it right there that's where it's got to
come from okay and then the other way
that I would do it kind of hurt a bit
the other thing that I would do is uh
talk about what you're going through so
what are the challenges that you're
facing right now talk about this talk
about the fear of going on YouTube
talking about the fear of not having the
support of your parents talk about all
that stuff things that you are currently
going through right now because that
will inspire other people who are going
through those same problems and how
you're doing and how you're overcoming
it and people on people to follow you on
your journey could be another great way
for you to motivate people without
having to be the expert on everything
right saying I don't know how to do this
but I don't want to live in regret for
the rest of my so I'm trying to figure
it out and this is my path I hope you
guys will join me on and you'll get lots
of support one more again notice it too
but I got three the third one is I would
interview people who you look up to who
have a message that you can learn from
right so if you look up to whatever
public speaker or whatever author
whatever youtuber asked him an interview
with them and ask them questions that
not only help you but also will help
your audience so by that combination of
one sharing what you know authentically
right I'm not going to pound this heart
this time and then to sharing what
you're going through right now your
future concerns your worries your
journey and then three interviewing
people who are ahead of you who you look
up to who have an inspired message as
well that you can learn from and pull
questions from to help inspire your
audience that's gold man that's cool and
maybe this isn't you know you start on
YouTube maybe you go somewhere else and
you follow some where the path and
that's okay right life is not this
straight line you're gonna wobble all
over the place but the only way to go
from here to here is a start right if
you're just staying down here and you're
not taking any action because your
parents tell you that you suck and
they're laughing at you you never
get to where you want to go okay follow
your passion change your environment
start making it impact and I'm gonna
start following you want to see that
video all right good luck that's it
believe I'll talk you soon man